the jurogan experience i mean i worry
about it you kind of go what happens
when the progressives convince facebook
that san francisco
is is dangerous yeah and that's not
outside the realm of possibility at all
the this thing that you say about
silencing you that's not outside the
realm of possibility you know i've seen
it i mean we were talking about barry
weiss earlier she got [ __ ] basically
pushed out of the new york times because
of
this sort of ideology that's spreading
rampant through journalism
and journalism has become slash activism
and then there's this idea that you have
to do
whatever you can and by any means
necessary push your agenda and silence
the oppressors you know even if these
suppressors are people like you that are
just saying listen you've got to take a
more radical approach to dealing with
these ever-growing problems and one of
the ways might be this carrot in the
stick and this idea that you have to
give people consequences for their
actions and reward people for good
actions and we could possibly like build
people back up but we're gonna have to
do it in a way that's gonna make folks
uncomfortable yeah i mean it's
definitely it seems like two things are
going on at once right there's
definitely this top-down effort at
censorship and including of people like
me in fact i was censored by facebook
you were i was how so um when my last
book came out they censored um true
facts which book is the apocalypse never
this one yep um
yeah
why environmental alarmism hurts us all
yeah that came out in june of last year
and i was censored um in the article i
wrote about it
and now other people that write about
climate change are being censored
i will say though you know i mean how so
were you censored like what did you say
they put a they put a uh they put a
like a warning label on the article that
was being shared that was the initial
article announcing the book saying this
contains misleading and false
information it's not true didn't contain
a single piece of false information and
misleading
is a really subjective thing right what
did you say that they objected to the
main so the main issues were i point out
that we're not in the in the midst of a
mass extinction
uh a mass extinction is when over when
75 or 90 of all species on earth are
are extinct or going extinct in fact
only six percent of species are
critically endangered and most of them
should or will survive
the other one is i pointed out that
natural disasters are not getting worse
deaths from natural disasters have
declined over 90 of the last hundred
years we're just much better at dealing
with hurricanes and floods and
and you know non-climate-related
disasters like earthquakes as well
um
and so what they they respond you know
that on the disasters they point out
that there's some evidence that
hurricanes are becoming somewhat more
intense but then they leave out the fact
that the best available science predicts
that hurricanes will become 25 percent
less frequent but five percent more
intense north atlantic hurricanes but it
but i even that doesn't matter because
our just we're just so much better at
preparing for hurricanes so like
vanishingly a few people die i think
something like
in the most recent i think 2019
something like 400 americans died of
natural disasters right it's like 300
because i was like 300 times more people
died of drug deaths in the united states
than from natural disasters i mean this
is how these two books work together
is me as a as someone that considers
myself liberal or moderate i used to be
progressive i don't use that label
anymore but my view is the drug crisis
is objectively a much bigger threat to
human life and to civilization than
climate change like we're adapted really
well to climate change we should do
something about it it's real there are
risks associated with it but like
there's no scenario in the
intergovernmental panel on climate
change
of climate change killing 93 000
americans a year in fact there's no
scenario of it killing of it of
increasing deaths from natural disasters
at all is it why is it more attractive
why is that a more attractive talking
point because this is one of the things
that you keep hearing from
uh whether it's whistleblowers at
news organizations where they're saying
that climate change is the next thing
they're looking at it according to you
know these people that are talking about
it they're they're looking at climate
change as the next thing that's going to
freak people out enough to guarantee
ratings niche yeah i mean i
i look at the so both of these books are
similar in the sense that i debunk
popular myths i explain what the
solutions are and then i also explore
why it is that say the people that say
they're the most concerned about climate
change oppose
the main solutions to reducing carbon
emissions or adapting to climate change
basically the three things won't
surprise you there's financial interests
there's just sort of a broader will to
power both kind of status and politics
and just kind of i'm going to jet around
the world and tell people how to live
their lives which is hilarious and often
happens yes
and then the third is um religion and
that you know the death of god what
nietzsche called the death of god which
is basically we just stop believing in
traditional religions whether it's
judaism or christianity or buddhism or
hinduism as we stop believing in
traditional religions
we still have a fear of death we still
have a need to believe in some higher
power and so we make new religions and
the problem with the new religions
whether it's climate apocalypse or
wokism or victimology the problem is
that the people
that are that are the adherents to those
new religions don't think that they're
promoting a new religion they think that
they're just being more compassionate or
i'm just being more sensitive or
whatever yeah so they're actually more
they're more dogmatic than the people in
the traditional religions because you
know you meet people that have even
evangelical views they'll always be like
well you know i am an evangelical
christian right so they have some
awareness of it but but folks that are
they don't like these people don't go
well i am an apocalyptic
environmentalist what they say is
they go they go i'm more aware of the
science or you know i'm i just love
nature and i just care about poor people
more than you it's always cast in some
sort of highly charged moralizing
framework you know which is like this
idea you know it's like this the main
idea of the folks that that have created
the the disaster in our cities is that
they care more that's the conceit you
know it's it's the
i just care more than you do you are
just more you're just insensitive
total [ __ ] but that kind of
emotional that kind of appeal to emotion
um has has a lot of power
watch the entire episode for free only
on spotify